[Music]
you drive there my feet are side-by-side
everyone got that
so the problem part I need I need to
send his direction and the other and the
other vector but I do it by having him
go forward and turning him around
remember that exactly okay I'm not
making him go forward and I shove him
out first
I take his forward energy I make a
little loop at the end and it goes down
forward and that
correction but okay that question is a
high on how do I do that well first
thing you're gonna make connection at
your arm
you don't make connection by clashing
him because then his head won't go
forward so you bring him into your heart
center he doesn't think he okay doesn't
come to your head say you should be here
that I bring him to money do you
understand
you know you don't know the technique so
you just do the kimi which is just a
push a push straight that's it and then
i bring him in to me to that contact
point do you understand okay forget us
and go boom you just do your push then i
bring him to that point i bring him
there do you see that so my elbow has to
come to my centerline oh whoa send your
ID now i have it touching now i have to
do i key so he has to I don't push into
him and I don't break I have that
perfect neutral friction where I can't
him to go standstill is that it's the
same thing I'm not going with nope
nothing
we're a gap or pushing I just have the
right amount of friction that gets that
to move you understand me
because you guys are exactly some of
your yeah Pete you're here doctor it's
not gonna go backwards and some of you
are shoving in that's not the same thing
because you're not letting to go forward
there you go here you bring him in and
now that perfect about a friction
that's what brings him around it's not
his job to do that he comes in right and
then the offense is back no it's not his
job
one two connection and now I'm using
Akeem
[Music]
if you push in them you won't get it
you'll clash if you break from him you
won't get it there won't be any contact
so one here that's what I want and now
that birthday goodbye appreciate hard
you're gonna want it to go like that are
you gonna go like that just ride on it
so right up right on that so it moves
right on it don't move don't move right
right on it
try your best when you have the momentum
it's easier okay I'm showing it in it's
harder stay where you go from side to
side when you add the momentum it's much
easier but you can still lose it all
together if you're gapping or if you're
shoving it
you see mid-foot weight not on my heels
mid-foot weight my torso has already
that count for the rear posterior chain
then I bring him in and then it's a
spiral going up that sends him back the
other way
here and this is fine what happens over
me
oh now we have contact then I follow
that in so I'm not pushing him down I'm
creating a geometry where he cannot
stand up any longer
so that's the tilt and then I step into
now with my body position in connection
the amount of pressure we discussed but
the pattern is a spiral going like this
this way till into the empty space this
tsuki behind him into the space position
you see how it's locked
Oh spiral into the space and we just
putting that together
okay trying to get so sacred shape do
you understand it's not like this whoa
no here oh okay let's go so the initial
Kazushi is right there so I am NOT
throwing him I'm aiming the following
one remember that rule okay so if that's
the case I don't want to use hip
rotation don't use it it has nothing to
do with it and that reduces the torque
across all the sinews and fast shot and
in the front of your body
when you turn your body there's no
torque now and we want those tissues to
be torque so they get conditioned so
don't use your hips you're here just
take a stance then finish the torch no
like this don't do that you're going to
be pushing him boom into the free space
fish pull them the torque and you just
put get rid of all the seams
okay let's go
is your kids not going in the other
direction until you all had let's
started moving not with I see that and
that means that's a clash they need to
be going in the other direction at the
completion of the spiral room
so our drill is going to stop there
whether your hand at the top position
the whole connection and then you do the
spiral
it'll stop there right it's not going
that way so that's your draw want to see
everyone's hand at the top can't go